[Music]
this is a Fox News Alert any moment now
the president will be addressing
supporters in Lake Charles Louisiana
just before arriving the president
announced the departure of his acting
DHS secretary he should plenty to say
tonight - about Ukraine his 2020 rivals
and who knows what else was a remarkable
rally last night we expect another
tonight will go to the president as soon
as he begins to speak but in the
meantime good evening and welcome to
Tucker Carlson tonight an update on a
story we've been following for the last
few days so by day Steve Kerr is the
coach of the Golden State Warriors
basketball team in the state of
California but in his spare time Kerr
moonlights as a political pundit he's
always happy to share his hot take on
American politics he's like a one-man
Twitter the president's a racist he'll
say and you have too many guns when
Steve Kerr talks like that the people
around him applaud
they think he's brave for saying things
that not a single person in their world
disagrees with it's the kind of bravery
that echoes consensus and boughs before
power which is to say it's not bravery
at all it's cowardice just the other day
someone asked Eve Kerr what he thinks of
the government of China the government
that's constructed the largest police
state in the history of the human race
maybe because the NBA does do a great
deal of business in China Kerr suddenly
seemed flummoxed by the question fascism
or democracy it's a tough choice he said
I don't want to weigh in but as Steve
Kerr discovered last night sometimes you
don't have a choice he was asked again
about China and this time he answered
the question sure he said China has
problems but so does the United States
and China is a racist ethno state that
sends religious minorities to
concentration camps and executes
political prisoners to steal their
organs but in America they sell guns at
Walmart so really there's a moral
equivalence there it has not come up in
terms of people asking me about it
people discussing it know
nor has our record of human rights
abuses come up either people in China
didn't ask me about you know people
owning air or 15's and mowing each other
down in a mall I wasn't asked that
question the world is a complex place
and there's more gray than black and
white some things aren't that great
though like putting Muslims in
concentration camps by the hundreds of
thousands Steve Kerr in the NBA it turns
out were made for each other tailor-made
the NBA epitomizes modern woke capital
ruthlessness under the guise of
compassion so of course they employ Kerr
who epitomizes the modern mindless elite
left Kerr is happy to trash his own
country whenever he gets the chance he
gets to feel good doing it and gives up
not one thing in return
he receives only accolades but when real
evil stares him in the face he has
nothing to say what's the difference the
difference is real evil is powerful and
there are costs to opposing it you can
get hurt there also rewards for
accepting it but if Kerr and the NBA
have made their choice very clear
earlier this week NBA Commissioner Adam
Silver claimed the NBA's ready to stand
by free speech no matter what the
consequences from China he lapped up the
subsequent praise from the press corps
which is no surprise our media loves to
cover for China too but it was all a lie
several NBA teams are currently on an
exhibition tour in China right now so
that presents a rare opportunity unlike
ordinary people superstar NBA players
can say whatever they want they could
speak their minds about China's regime
they could get attention and avoid
consequences you're gonna put some NBA
player in jail no they had a golden
opportunity to speak real truth to real
power but the NBA stopped them today the
NBA announced that none of the players
on the tour in China will be able to
speak to the media for the rest of the
trip wouldn't want any of them using
their free speech the wrong way and
criticizing their Chinese masters
they're all like this by the way the
coach the San Antonio Spurs begged
Popovich he's aggressively politically
calls the president of Seoul
coward who brings up the dark side human
beings
okay whatever in 2016 he bragged that as
an American he was allowed to speak his
mind on anything yeah that's absolutely
right but what is he using that free
speech for he's not using it at all when
asked about the NBA and China which is a
critically critical issue as of today
Popovich has nothing to say
they said he blasted Trump for his
handling of the Jamal khashoggi
assassination last year that's a
non-sequitur I mean whatever but what
does that after you a China nothing why
do you answer that well because Saudi
Arabia has a smaller basketball market
than China does there's no risk by the
way where's Daleks Matt Dallas Mavericks
owner Mark Cuban he's never been afraid
to speak his mind he's got an
interesting mind and a lot to say he's
come on this show at least once maybe
twice so tell us what he thinks but so
far he's had nothing at all to say about
China and its control over the NBA so
what does all of this prove it proves
what you've known for a long time the
ruling class is totally phony they're
weak and they're pathetic and that's
obvious now they talk a big game about
human rights we care about people happy
to lecture you about democracy and about
their own moral vitality they're way
more impressive than you are but it was
all a sham they didn't mean a word of it
the single biggest threat to your
freedoms right now as Americans is not
Russia or Saudi Arabia or Iran or Donald
Trump no the single greatest threat to
your freedom right now as you well know
we all know is China China's the threat
and anyone who pretends otherwise isn't
simply clueless they're an accomplice